c'est la fille de johnny hallyday l'une
des deux filles c'est jade qui a fait un
post instagram cette semaine qu'on va
voir
voilà où il était en anglais mais qui
dit mon cher papa ta lumière et en août
à force et ton courage nous porte à
jamais maman joy et moi nous t'aimons où
tu nous manques tellement tous les jours
jusque là saleh est la phrase d'après
évidemment fait polémique
parce que l'amour est plus fort que les
mensonges mais quand je dis que ça fait
polémique
y en a qui disent que c'est laeticia
hallyday qu'il a écrits de sa main sur
le compte de sa fille en
instrumentalisant sa fille autour de
tout ça et de toute cette histoire pour
de la com et là mêmes qui vont jusqu'à
eu jusqu'à appeler des pédopsychiatres
pour voir les anciens instar de jade
pour voir si c'est ce que vous y êtes
pourrez poster ça c'est dans son c'est
dans sa manière de l'écrire c'est dans
le cerveau d'un enfant
ça prend des proportions énormes donc là
est-ce qu'il ya instrumentalisation
pardon de l'enfant ou pas et puis
l'autre question qu'on se pose c'est si
c'est sincère et qu'elle l'a vraiment
écrit est-ce que laëtitia aurait dû
laisser sa fille écrire un tweet à ce
point polémique en pleine histoire qui
me prend la parole là dessus
mathieu moi la chose qui me choque c'est
pas la phrase c'est la photo qui
illustre parce que la photo c'est une
photo typique de photographes
regardez c'est pas une photo spontanée
qu'un adolescent mais on voit bien que
c'est un truc complètement réfléchi
pensé elles sont chacune là avec la main
donc voilà non il n'ya pas la
spontanéité d'un adolescent qui publie
sur instagram avec cette photo là et
pour vous sur un très clair laëtitia a
été voir ja dans 10 ans ma chérie tu
poses de cette photo tu écris ça suffit
les mensonges et ça s'est passé comme ça
non j mc c'est forcément leur mère mais
on sent que c'est très très réfléchie
quoi et quand c'est un truc derrière qui
voyez il ya un truc très réfléchie qui
est bizarre et qui surtout est en
rupture avec les précédents les
précédentes publications llc à jade 14
14 ans bon très bien guillaume lui à
part dans sébastien fait en tant que
vous a pas entendu
bah ça c'est une faute professionnelle
donc
comment ils se les procurer ou est-ce
qu'elle a eu les droits de les diffuser
sur son instagram
non c'est parce que donc qui lui a donné
l'autorisation de passer cette photo ll
n'a pas fait d'elle-même tout ça c'est
ça qui peut paraître bizarre moi c'est
la photo qui me venait d'un photographe
professionnel qui eut envoyé en aidant
la photo est très jolie elle est libre
de droit face arrive ça c'est là c'est
moi mais engueuler excusez-moi instagram
c'est un réseau social ou en poste en
général de jolies photos
souvent on fait les shootings et qu'on
garde de côté donc la petite c'est tout
à fait normal qu'elle ait des photos du
shooting
surtout que c'est des célébrités même l
action hyper connus qu'amendé faut pas
prendre les enfants n'ont plus où les
ados pour des imbéciles à la 14 ans les
droits aujourd'hui mes gamins c'est une
photo de shooting à l'aller
oui mais pour elle à les solutionner
voilà est sûre le sur le tweet je pense
qu'à 14 ans les ados sont beaucoup plus
intelligents que ce que voulaient les
femmes là les faire va passer pardon moi
je me perds mais elle elle dit des mots
qu'elle pense elle voit son histoire de
vie partout dans la presse elle voit
tout l analyse tout tient la petite
c'est normal aussi qu'elle est elle a
posté sa mère les aides c'est qu'en ce
moment les conséquences sont énormes le
moindre mot fait d'armes entre les
écarts entre les parts ont ri elle fait
des instants story on l'a vu il n'ya pas
longtemps où elle est en live mais si
elle l'a fait y avait pas sa mère
derrière qui lui disait fais toi et dans
les autres et story elle dit ça suffit
les mensonges bande de journalistes pour
ça j'essaie d'évoquer longtemps sur fait
d'évoquer la alors qu'elle resterait en
même temps parce que sur twitter je vous
le dis et franchement dieu sait si on
lit tout ce que vous dites
cette semaine c'est à nouveau un petit
peu trop les uns sur les autres que vous
parlez donc discipline s'il vous plaît
guillaume et daniel non mais juste moi
je trouve que vous êtes en train
d'imaginer que laëtitia c'est le diable
c'est un monstre qui veut que l'argent
qui manipulent les deux petites les
petitesses en 14 ans leur mère c'est
leur mère elles ont perdu leur père
depuis moins d'un an
elles voient leurs frères à l'antenne il
est ultra sincère de canon sont âgées de
quelques jours par le magma absolue
elles défendent leur mère et elle ont
peut-être entendu il y en a elle répète
le truc et elles ont peut-être dit à
leur mère maman je vais mettre ça et la
mer a dit ma chérie fais ce que tu veux
vous et pourquoi imaginer les trucs
quand on délire ce que vous faites quand
des bisous à chaque fois non c'est pas
le monde et si vous optez bisounours
vous c'est le monde signifie pas moi
niel ce que je trouve dommage c'est
qu'en fait david est le seul dans cette
histoire qui pense aux quatre enfants en
même temps c'est à dire que par exemple
il a été blessé par une interview de
mamy rock qu'elle a donné je crois sur
m6 où elle disait qu'elle avait entendu
johnny dire que les deux aînés étaient
le dial donc lui ce qu on al impression
vraiment que c'est le seul qui voudrait
que les quatre enfants soient aussi bien
loti les uns que les autres pour le
droit moral pour tous il ne les oublie
jamais il les a pas oubliés ils avaient
déjà été très très très humain avec elle
avoue donc justement je trouve dommage
que jade qui que ce soit une initiative
personnelle ou une initiative qu'on lui
a un petit peu dicté je trouve dommage
qu'elle ne se rendent pas compte et je
trouve triste pour david que la fratrie
commence à être 10 voyages détruits
en fait je pense qu'elle fait allusion
au fait que david a dit dans l'interview
qu'il n'avait pas eu accès à la à la
chambre de son père au moment de mourir
et il a laissé sous-entendre que
laëtitia ce moment là là à donner des
ordres au service médical pour qu'il ne
rentre pas je pense que c'est ça enfin
cela parce que en fait moi les infos que
j'ai eu c'est que les proches ont
vraiment de laëtitia ont l'impression
que la david refait l'histoire ce cas au
moment où ça s'est passé
visiblement david donc été est resté
toute la journée sur le canapé à
attendre pour rentrer et à ce moment là
il a peut-être cru qu effectivement
laetitia l'empêcher de venir mais moins
les infos qu'on m'avait donné c'était
que à ce moment-là laëtitia était en
train de dormir ce cas les passagers
c'est vrai que sa soeur parle tout ça
que les pillages en colère après
l'interview de 7 à 8 minuit et les visas
et un peu l'espoir je suis désolé faut
vraiment qu'on qu'on avance un tout
petit peu tu veux dire un dernier mot
circuit devrait engendrer un livre sur
johnny hallyday qui serait de dire moi
qui s'appelle les larmes de johnny j'ai
fait une enquête et non en fait johnny
ne voulait pas que david et laura le
voit et laetitia a obtempéré aux
volontés de johnny elle aurait dû à ce
moment-là dire non non mais lui il
aurait très bien pu aussi allait
s'avérer plus longtemps rappelons juste
une chose mais chatel montrer ni jal ni
jeunes ne sont sur le testament
ouais non plus rappelons le graal absolu